all right Santa star gets in a fight at
an NBA game you saw this yeah
yeah what did you think
this is another actor is that what you
think
he had an accent too I think he's also
leaning into the character of being so
Pro LeBron like he's gonna go to the
lake uh Lakers game Courtside and if
something happens he ain't gonna be
scared of it and it was the argument
with Team Morant Jaws well it started
with Dylan Brooks yeah who was playing
who's playing yeah something like sit
your ass down then Shannon talked back
well he initially said he was too small
to guard LeBron okay so he said that
before the game he's like this guy you
can't put him against the bar he's too
small so he was chirping him before
anything even started and then after I
think LeBron like shot over him or
whatever then he was like see told you
and then he says um shut up shut the
[__] up whatever then they start drawing
back and forth then Steven Adams comes
over and
he don't care he's ready and then that
they kind of get separated a little bit
then John Moran's dad comes over and
then him and John Moran's dad are going
at it much harder but Emma John Mary's
dad are cool they already showed that
yeah yeah but Stephen A Smith released
the army star Shannon sharp released a
little statement after this has
something like these guys didn't want
smoke uh Team around didn't want no
smoke Dylan Brooks didn't want no smoke
he conveniently left Stephen Adams out
of it he might like a little bit I
wanted to smoke a small aperitif of
smoke perhaps should be okay with him a
puff let's take a put Shannon wanted to
smoke too I surprised he wasn't like
backing down
yeah yeah yeah yeah
but he could the whole team could have
pretty much came after him and he just
bought himself that's all I believe but
he also knows that nobody's gonna do
[__] hey at the [__] Lakers State
like what is it yeah there's no way I
think he really does probably like
LeBron but I also think Skip is the
anti-lebron guy so the best role to play
is the very Pearl LeBron guy and then
you watch Skip and you learn it doesn't
have to be that real for skip is not
real at all for Shannon it's like well
let me just lean in all the way here's
an opportunity to elevate my my profile
as an announcer Beyond Hall of Fame
football player and it's funny and he
handles himself well in the situation
and it's like he wearing the Fire card
again they already got the [__] album
cover that you've seen that oh yeah with
his parental advisory and he's looking
in the album with The Cardigans woman or
whatever he bet your whole style bro I
know yeah he wanted to be cardigan but
we're going to see some privilege If he
if he doesn't get banned from the arena
yeah because any other person you think
that black privilege yeah let's go
that's why Alex Baldwin's getting
charged this didn't happen to OJ that's
a good ass Point what's happening
what's happening
oh yeah he got charged he innocent he
walking free yeah well let's see yeah
but yeah not even gonna get charged and
he's what happened at where it happened
at Staples or whatever the [__] they
call it now crypto crypto.com yeah
yeah I don't know if it's at if it's at
crypto
nothing happens to him I think LeBron
just squashes that [__] immediately
LeBron said something like I love see
Shannon that's my guy that's the stuff
yeah